bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette petite vidéo enfin cette
série de vidéos qu'on va faire sur la
théorie du singe aquatique ou comme
l'appelle mon très cher collègue le
docteur raphaël à nom de la chaîne
archéo cave que je vous recommande
comme il l'appelle la théorie de la cua
man c'est à dire l'origine de l'homme à
travers une phase aquatique je trouve
que aquaman ça lui va parfaitement à cet
e à cette théorie alors on va faire une
série de trois vidéos la première vidéo
celle-ci où je vais en gros vous
expliquer le concept de pourquoi cette
théorie absolue scientifique et pourquoi
les scientifiques ne la prennent pas au
sérieux et ensuite on va faire deux
autres vidéos ou dans lesquels je vais
débarquer des contenus en français ou
francophones y est sûre la théorie sur
cette théorie donc la théorie du singe
aquatique la théorie du primate
aquatique bon alors cette théorie déjà
qu'est ce qu'elle dit alors elle dit
c'est une petite fantaisie on va dire
qui dit que l'hominisation alors des
gens on utilise des termes désuet j'ai
envie de dire le ministation c'est à
dire le le fait que l'homme se redresse
sur ses pattes de derrière deviennent
bipèdes et que son cerveau augmente de
taille
cette mobilisation est le fruit d'une
adaptation au milieu aquatique le milieu
aquatique permettant un soutien du corps
grâce à la poussée d'archimède
permettant la stature bipèdes et le
cerveau est en lui-même un organe
relativement lourd en fête aurait alors
dans certaines versions c'est juste
grâce à la poussée d'archimède c'est
plus facile de tenir le cerveau enfin la
tête droite et dans d'autres versions
c'est carrément le cerveau c'est en gros
un organe de flottabilité alors
maintenant j'appelle ça une petite
fantaisie parce que bon bah les théories
sur l'origine de l'homme enfin de
l'évolution humaine en général pas
seulement de l'homme ce sont ceux c'est
un peu comme les trous du cul tout le
monde en a une voilà des opinions sur
l'évolution humaine de manière néral
tout le monde en a une et c'est pas une
raison pour la montrer à tout le monde
surtout que la plupart du temps elle est
plutôt sale donc le et la théorie du
singe aquatique a fait plutôt partie des
théories salle on va dire des théories
qui sont pas du tout accepté alors c'est
pas parce que c'est pas parce que les
l'anthropologie la fin les médias font
passer l'anthropologie et la
paléoanthropologie pour
pour un milieu dans laquelle les guerres
de quéquette sont plus fortes que la
science ce genre ce serait un combat dgo
tous les niveaux et puis on 300c jamais
rien parce que tous les deux semaines
s'est remis en question et puis façon
moi je fais pas la différence entre 3
millions d'années et deux cent mille ans
alors on peut bien dire ce qu'on veut et
où
la paléoanthropologie c'est une science
il ya des données qu'ils sont solides
qu'ils sont alors il ya des fossiles par
milliers il y a des datations fiable il
faut que quelle que soit la théorie que
vous mettez sur pied il va falloir
qu'elle passe par certains points
ces points ce sont les fossiles ce sont
les observations de terrain sur la
primatologie moderne bref et puis ces
points ça va être aussi juste de la
logique de base aussi des fois ça sert à
quoi peut servir donc et la théorie donc
des singes aquatique ne remplit pas ces
conditions elle ne passe pas partout les
points elle va négliger des points elle
va faire ce qu'on appelle dit cherry
picking cueillir les arguments là où ça
les arrange elle va ignorer comme il
faut tout le concept de datation 1 comme
toutes les théories bullshit sur
l'évolution humaine il ya deux temps le
présent et le reste là le passé le passé
que ce soit 400 millions d'années trois
milliards d'années deux millions
d'années ou deux cent mille ans
c'est pareil c'est pareil pour la
théorie du primate aquatique tant qu'on
peut aller chercher vous voyez tant
qu'on peut aller à la pêche aux
arguments comme quoi hommes et regardez
là ça c'est bien cohérent avec ma
théorie
qu'importe l'âge que ça qu importe si
c'est pas cohérent avec le reste on
garde donc tout ça on va l'expliquer
aujourd'hui 1 pourquoi pourquoi les
pourquoi la théorie du singe aquatique
ne fonctionne pas mais en gros la
première chose qu'il faut savoir c'est
que ça fait partie de ces théories en
gros que les gens soutiennent parce que
parce que voilà moi j'ai une opinion
j'ai envie qu'elle soit en vie qu'elles
soient contredites j'ai envie qu'elle
aille à l'encontre j'ai envie de me
sentir comme galilée voilà que d'avoir
la doxa scientifiques contre moi parce
que ça me fait me sentir un petit flocon
de neige merveilleux et unique donc ça
c'est j'ai un truc c'est un schéma
narratif on va dire voilà c'est un
schéma narratif qu'on recouvre donc on
retrouve tout le temps cette théorie qui
cherche absolument à être contre ce que
contre les théories classiques
voilà mais les théories classiques sont
classiques précisément parce que elle
passe par des preuves voyez donc elles
peuvent pas changer de trajectoire comme
ça comme elles veulent à tous les coins
de rue faut qu'elle passe comme je les
dis par les fossiles et par les
observations et voilà donc il n'ya pas
de vous voulez la théorie classique néo
classique que parce que justement il
faut qu'elle passe par certains
checkpoint il ya déjà des points de
passages obligatoires que sont les
preuves justement donc parlons-en des
preuves donc déjà on va parler d'abord
des preuves et donc des preuves que je
qualifierais de recevable donc les arts
ou les arguments on peut les appeler les
arguments je suis vous voulez si vous
vous êtes allergiques au mot preuves
mais bref les arguments qui sont qui
serait recevable
en faveur de la théorie du singe
aquatique la théorie du singe aquatique
elle fait hélas partie un peu comme la
théorie de l'origine européenne de
l'humanité la théorie du singe aquatique
elle fait hélas partie de ces théories
pour lesquelles je peux vous récitez
l'épreuve de tête en seulement quelques
secondes
les voici
vous n'avez rien vu et rien entendu
c'est normal y en a pas il n'y a pas de
preuve en faveur de la théorie du singe
aquatique des arguments plus ou moins
foireux ça y'en a dans la des milliers
on va voir dans cette série de vidéos
notamment dans la dernière la troisième
vidéo vous allez voir qu'il ya des
millefeuilles argumentatif qui envoie du
pâté 1
l'info qu'une infographique on va
décortiquer qui est plein d'arguments
foireux donc ça de l'argument foireux on
va en voir des vous savez les arguments
foireux cesser les preuves
circonstancielles c'est les petites
idées reçues les trucs les trucs qui
sont cohérents avec une origine
aquatiques mais qui en même temps
peuvent être tellement mieux expliquées
par autre chose que
ça n'a que ça n'a aucun sens de les
mettre là et donc on les empile comme ça
on les empile on les empile ça fait un
millefeuille argumentatif oui mais bon
1000 milles mauvais argument ça vaut pas
un bon argument
c'est c'est le principe du millefeuille
argumentatif par exemple les preuves
circonstancielles les doigts quand vous
les mettez dans l'eau il se plie c'est
ça permet de mieux attraper les objets
dans l'eau alors évidemment là les
tenants de la théorie du singe aquatique
vous disais pourquoi on aurait ce pour
quoi on aurait 7 moyens d'agripper les
objets dans l'eau si on n'avait pas un
ancêtre aquatique je suis d'accord
pourquoi mais dans ce cas là pourquoi
tous les autres singes ont aussi est ce
que oui les autres singes n'est pas
seulement les grands singes tous les
singes les autres singes ont aussi ça
les doigts le bout des doigts qui se
plissent quand on les met dans l'eau et
pour autant qu'on sache ils sont pas
plus aquatiques que nous alors ou alors
ça veut dire que l'ancêtre de tous les
singes les ancêtres de tous les singes
étaient tous aquatique et que soudain on
sait pas pourquoi tous les singes
modernes sont devenus pas aquatique
bail est elle est déjà là on commence
donc ça c'est le genre de petit preuves
circonstancielles qui sont pas vraiment
des preuves sont des arguments ça passe
par là c'est évoquer il faut pas trop y
réfléchir si vous voulez il faut pas se
renseigner faut pas chercher à se
renseigner pour pour lier pour y croire
et c'est exactement ça les arguments du
en faveur du singe aquatique donc les
preuves que j'appellerais recevables les
arguments recevables si vous n'aimez pas
le mot preuve eh bien ça va être des
arguments qui serait capable de faire
pencher la balance des scientifiques
voilà des choses qui sont capables de
convaincre les scientifiques que la
théorie du singe aquatique est recevable
ces épreuves là y'en a pas non
absolument pas alors on va on va
décortiquer tout ça en commençant
d'abord par
ce que j'appellerais l'épreuve d'après
les observations des espèces modernes
grand 1 les espèces modernes
imaginez sa présentation powerpoint
grand
donc déjà chez les espèces modernes est
ce que l'on constate comme le prévoit la
théorie de des grands singes des singes
aquatique pardon est ce que l'on
constate une association entre bipédie
et mode de vie aquatique ou semi
aquatique
la réponse est non il n'ya pas
d'association entre mode de vie
aquatique et bipédie chez aucun animal
connu aujourd'hui alors il ya
éventuellement quelques oiseaux
aquatiques qui sont à la fois bipèdes et
aquatiques mais je rappelle que les
oiseaux et temps des dinosaures la
bipédie chez les dinosaures elle date du
trias et les premiers dinosaures
aquatiques dont qui est semi aquatique
qui ont commencé à vivre dans l'eau bah
c'est penser en ce cas raptor
spinosaurus
ikhtiyar nice espère ornis tout ça ça
date du crétacé donc il ya un gouffre
d'à peu près à la louche
il ya un petit gouffre d'à peu près 80
millions d'années entre l'acquisition de
la bipédie est là et le mode de vie
semi-aquatique chez les oiseaux donc le
mode de vie semi-aquatique et enfin le
mode de vie semi aquatique et la bipédie
chez les oiseaux et les ancêtres des
oiseaux donc les dinosaures globalement
ça marche pas ça marche il n'y a pas de
lien entre bipédie et mode de vie
aquatique chez les chez les dinosaures
donc et c'est à peu près les seuls
animaux qu'on peut rencontrer
aujourd'hui comme les canards par
exemple qui soit à la fois bipèdes et
semi aquatique mais après si vous pensez
aux loutres si vous pensez aux
pinnipèdes si vous pensez aux siréniens
si vous pensez aux cétacés aux
hippopotames
même les serpents qui nagent les iguanes
qui nagent les importe quelle espèce il
n'existe pas d'animaux aujourd'hui qui
soit à la fois bipèdes et aquatiques
sont tous quadrupèdes même les ours les
ours ils sont ils sont capables de
bipédie mais quand ils chassent le
poisson le saumon ils sont quadrupèdes
ils se tiennent sur leurs quatre pattes
le nez dans l'eau enfin le nez tourné
vers la flotte époux flics comme ça
qu'ils attrapent les poissons quoi donc
la bipédie c'est même pas un avantage en
fait quand on quand on se met dans l'eau
et qu'on se cherche à se nourrir dans
l'eau puisque la nourriture elle est
dans l'eau quand donc la bipédie la
bipédie qui consisterait à avoir comme
le prévoit la théorie de du singe
aquatique la théorie qui consiste à
avoir la tête en dehors de lola comme
[ __ ] jusqu'ici la tête qui flotte au
sommet et le corps droit sous l'eau qui
vous permet justement d'acquérir cette
posture bipèdes c'est ridicule parce que
l'eau la nourriture elle est dans la
flotte
donc vous avez besoin de regarder dans
l'eau vous avez besoin de regarder dans
l'eau l'être humain il est il à il n'a
aucune adaptation à regarder dans l'eau
on a nos organes des sens sont
absolument inadapté à la
sentir les choses qui se passent dans
l'eau à voir à sentir à capter ce qui se
passe dans l'eau nos oreilles sont
incapables d'entendre sous l'eau
contrairement à celle des dauphins et
des hippopotames on n'a pas de moustache
contrairement aux otaries et aux loutres
qui permettent de sentir les vibrations
sous l'eau on n'a pas de
les nos yeux ne sont pas adaptés à voir
sous l'eau on n'a rien on n'a rien pour
pour sentir ce qui se passe sous l'eau
le mieux qu'on puisse faire sous l'os et
avancer à tâtons comme ça surtout
surtout si on part du principe que le
singe aquatique n'était pas marin mais
en eau en eau douce l'eau douce qui est
souvent très trouble
je veux dire on va on va jamais s'en
sortir bon bref donc les espèces
modernes il n'y a pas de d'espèces
aquatiques qui soit bipèdes et
al'inverse les espèces bipèdes donc
comme les oiseaux comme je les dis mais
aussi les kangourous on peut parler des
kangourous les espèces bipèdes sont pas
spécialement aquatique donc les
kangourous sont devenus bipèdes 200
besoin de de passer par une phase
aquatique connu donc c'est il n'ya pas
d'association chez les espèces modernes
y a pas d'association entre êtres
aquatique et être bipèdes donc déjà
votre théorie du singe bipèdes elle part
avec ce handicap
c'est pas seulement c'est pas seulement
qu'il ya une absence de preuve c'est que
là on a même une preuve contre elle
ensuite l'être humain at il des
adaptations à un mode de vie aquatique
alors on va vous sortir comme je disais
le mil fallait argumentative de tous les
petits détails à la noix qui peuvent
être expliqués de plein d'autres
manières différentes quels sont les
vrais arguments les vrais adaptation à
la vie aquatique qui ce qui pourrait
être vu sur un être humain et qui serait
indiscutablement des preuves que l'être
humain a une origine aquatique c'est ça
qu'on veut c'est ça qui nous intéresse
nous ce qu'on veut c'est une preuve qui
montrerait indiscutablement une
adaptation me de vie aquatique pas un
truc qui puisse être interprété
autrement
l'épreuve classique de l'adaptation au
mode de vie aquatique et qu'on utilise
classiquement en paléontologie pour
suggérer qu'un animal donc par exemple
ancêtres des cétacés l'ancêtre des
sirénia l'ancêtre des des loutres et des
pinnipèdes et tout ça pour suggérer
qu'ils étaient aquatique c'est toujours
les mêmes généralement c'est
premièrement ce qu'on appelle la pac et
aux stones ou pas qui ostéo sclérose
c'est-à-dire épaississement et
épaississement et densification donc
plus dense des eaux plus dense et plus
épais quoi du squelette et notamment on
va voir ça sur les os longs donc chez
les humains si on part du principe qu'il
ya une bipédie dans l'eau on devrait
voir des tibias enfin dès le fémur le
tibia la fibula et les os du tarse
devenir plus dense il devrait être plus
dense chez les êtres humains que les
autres haut du corps ce n'est pas le cas
et pourquoi ils devraient être plus
dense bas pour être maintenue au fond de
l'eau et ça on le voit aussi même chez
des espèces qui sont très faiblement
aquatiques comme le chevreuil aquatiques
par exemple le chevreuil aquatiques et
moss cus africanus je crois le chevrotin
aquatique à des eaux des membres très
dense ce qui lui permet quand il va dans
l'eau juste pour se cacher il se nourrit
même pas dans l'eau il va dans l'eau
juste pour se cacher et quand il va dans
l'eau pour se cacher ça lui permet de
rester tapi au fond de l'eau ça agit
comme un ballast en fait et ça lui
permet de rester tapi au fond de l'eau
ça l'être humain ne l'a pas voilà donc
première adaptation on l'a pas les
adaptations classique ça va inclure tout
ce qui est au niveau des membres on va
avoir développement d'une pâle mureaux -
ou d'un système qui permet de se mouvoir
dans l'eau parce que l'être humain c'est
quand même un des pires animaux pour ce
qui est de se mouvoir dans l'eau les
tenants de la théorie du singe
acoustique ils vont être là à vous dire
ah bah oui mais l'être humain il sait
nager quand même ouais alors l'être
humain il sait nager 15 secondes quand
il est à sa naissance et puis après ils
oublient il faut lui réapprendre quoi
enfin qu'un second que j'exagère mais je
veux dire les êtres humains savent nager
instinctivement au début de leur vie et
puis après c'est fini c'est oublié
prenez comparé à un chien vous prenez un
chien de n'importe quel âge vous le
balancer dans l'eau il saura nager
donc le chien ça veut dire que le chien
est mieux adapté à la vie aquatique que
l'être humain quoi si vous suivez cette
logique là je veux dire évidemment que
non évidemment que non mais voilà les
l'idée c'est que l'être humain c'est un
nageur pas terrible du tout et vous
prenez quelqu'un vous mettez quelqu'un
dans une piscine et vous lui demandez de
faire le 50 m de sa vie en crawl le plus
vite possible bah je vous assure que
vous le battre et à la course à pied à
côté si vous courez sur le côté de la
piscine faut pas le faire c'est
dangereux
mais si la piscine si le bord de la
piscine et bien c'est quelques le
carrelage a été et bien l'adhérent vous
pouvez couvrir à côté de la piscine et
vous verrez vous aurez aucun mal à
doubler la personne en train de nager le
crawl de sa vie parce que parce qu'on
est des nageurs pas terrible du tout on
n'a pas les mains palmer on n'a pas les
pieds palmés on a les pieds les pires du
monde pour nager ou pour marcher ne
serait ce qu'au fond de nous marcher au
fond de l'eau comment vous faites ça
avec des pieds humains alors les
hippopotames ils ont pas de paille mur
certes mais ils ont des doigts qui
s'écartent pour pouvoir justement marché
dans la vase
nous on n'a pas ça nous nos doigts ils
sont pas du tout écarté au contraire
c'est l'opposé de ce qu'on voit chez les
singes c'est à dire que chez les singes
vous avez notamment le pouce opposable
alors que chez les humains vous avez les
pousse sur les pieds qui sont alignés
avec le reste des autres doigts parce
que c'est une adaptation à la course
justement nous on est adapté à la course
de fond c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
adapté à courir très vite sur de courtes
distances on est adapté à courir
lentement sur de longues distances c'est
comme ça qu'on pense homo erectus
chassait est chassé à l'épuisement en
fait vu qu'ils chassaient des antilopes
et que les antilopes sont adaptés à
courir très vite même sur de courtes
distances en fait il peut puis trottine
derrière ping une petite flèche il
trottine derrière pim une petite flèche
c'est ce que font l'écho et san et au
bout d'un moment l'antilope elle
s'effondre parce qu'elle n'a pas de
moyens de réguler sa température
corporelle
aussi efficace que l'être humain l'être
humain est là un moyen très efficace il
a pas de poils
il a pas de poils donc la température
corporelle s'évacue et puis en plus on
transpire contrairement à la plupart des
animaux notamment les antilopes ça
marche aussi avec les zèbres ont
transpiré on transpire abondamment ça
nous refroidit très efficacement et du
coup on peut tenir très longtemps à
courir derrière les antilopes comme ça
dans la savane bon évidemment sa demande
sa demande qu'on ait grandi dans la
savane et qu'on soit un tant soit peu
coutumier de la pratique évidemment que
deux mâts si vous êtes un peu si on vous
parachute après la savane vous aurez un
peu de mal surtout si vous n'avez pas
l'habitude de l'habitude de quoi mais
enfin je veux dire faire le jogging
voyez vous avez déjà fait votre jogging
avec votre chien nous nos pieds sont
adaptés à cette ce mode de chasse c'est
à dire la épuisé les proies on a hérité
ça de moyens rectus et jusqu'à jusqu'à
très récemment jusqu'au néolithique
c'était comme ça que chasser nos
ancêtres du mois c'est ce que nous
raconte le registre archéologiques et
les paléoanthropologues
donc
notre pied il est l'opposé en fait de ce
qu'on attend d'eux d'un animal
semi-aquatique un animal semi-aquatique
aurait au contraire les doigts très
écartés par rapprocher enfin les orteils
très écartés et pas rapprochés comme ça
et puis il ya toutes les adaptations
qu'on devrait voir sur le crâne à savoir
que l'être humain a le crâne le plus
stupide du monde quand il s'agit d'être
semi aquatique si on est soumis tous les
animaux semi-aquatique enfin la plupart
des animaux semi aquatiques ont des yeux
situé au sommet du crâne ça leur permet
de s'immerger totalement
est de pouvoir regarder au dessus de
l'eau qui a pas des proies ou des
prédateurs en fonction de six et des
carnivores ou pas s'il n'y a pas des
proies ou des prédateurs qui sont en
train de passer par là
donc ça c'est ce qu'on voit chez la
plupart des espèces aquatiques et ils
ont aussi un nez qui est situé sur le
sommet du crâne qui leur permet aussi de
respirer et du coup quand
bah pareil quand ils sont immergés bombe
à nous pour avoir les yeux et le nez qui
ressorte de l'eau font qu'on se tienne
comme ça
parce que
parce qu'on n'a pas les yeux et les
narines au sommet du crâne idéalement on
devrait avoir les yeux ici et les
narines au milieu entre les deux là si
on était semi a adapté un tant soit peu
adapté aux milieux semi aquatique
au lieu de ça on a un espèce de front
gigantesque qui sortira de l'eau bien
avant nous et je vous rappelle que là ce
qui se passe là dedans c'est quand même
une des parties les plus importantes de
votre corps alors vous imaginez qu'en
gros à chaque fois que vous sortez de
l'eau ce qui est exposé en premier c'est
quasiment l'organe le plus vital que
vous puissiez exposés s'il ya un lion
qui vous attend à l'extérieur autrement
dit vous êtes foutus quoi où un
crocodile pour coup mais bref le le truc
c
c'est la partie où elle a plus une des
parties les plus importantes de votre
anatomie qui va sortir de l'eau avant
vos yeux qui vous permettront de
contrôler si oui ou non il ya un danger
ou pas et même si vous sortez vos yeux
vous avez encore les narines tourner
vers le bas 1
ça c'est un bon truc bien qu'on aussi
vous avez les narines tourner vers le
bas donc vous avez l'eau qui vous arrive
là les narines tourner vers le bas et
donc vous pouvez pas respirer tant que
vous n'avez pas regardé vous n'avez pas
un instant là tout votre front là qui
est exposée c'est c'est pas du tout
optimisé pour un mode de vie
semi-aquatique ça
donc et ça l'a avoir les yeux sur le
sommet du crâne généralement c'est
pareil c'est dans l'évolution des états
c'est dans l'évolution des de tous les
animaux semi aquatique c'est un d une
des premières adaptations qui ressort en
fait de ces animaux qui se sont adaptés
au mode de vie semi-aquatique avoir les
yeux plus haut et les narines plus haute
sur le crâne
l'être humain c'est l'opposé l'être
humain on voit que tout se développe
avec la face elle va se rétrécir devant
là comme ça c'est l'exact opposé qui a
lieu dans l'évolution humaine donc ça
c'est pareil c'est pas cohérent avec un
mode de vie aquatique et puis après les
adaptations physiologique au mode de vie
aquatique genre arrivé à retenir sa
respiration pendant une durée de
plusieurs minutes oui on en est capable
mais c'est pas le premier pelo venus qui
va y arriver donc tout ça et puis comme
je le disais il ya tous les organes des
sens évidemment on n'a aucun organes des
sens qui est adapté à la mode de vie
aquatique le seul organe le seul organe
d'essence qui a un tant soit peu
qui a un tant soit peu de sens si on lan
interprète du point de vue d'une
adaptation semi aquatique s'est
éventuellement les lobes golf actifs les
nobles fakty fume un son tout petit et
c'est effectivement quelque chose qu'on
retrouve chez beaucoup d'espèces
aquatiques notamment les cétacés les
sirènes
bon tous les primates ont des lobes
effectif réduit et ça s'explique très
bien par le fait que les primates sont
essentiellement des animaux visuel est
pas tellement des animaux olfactif n'en
veut pour preuve le fait que les que les
primates sont parmi les rares mammifères
à avoir une vue tri chromatique alors
que la plupart des mammifères ont une
vue by chromatique il compense avec un
odorat très développé donc ça c'est chez
les espèces modernes donc quand on
regarde les espèces modernes il aa
priori aucune et humains inclus il yaa
priori aucune raison de croire que
l'être humain possède des adaptations se
au milieu semi aquatique maintenant on
regarde les fossiles en regardant les
fossiles on va peut-être voir cette
adaptation peut-être que ces adaptations
sont apparus et ont disparu donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai insisté beaucoup sur
les adaptations hausse théologique les
adaptations physiologique du type va
être capable de stocker de la de
l'oxygène dans les muscles ce qui
permettrait justement de rester plus
longtemps sous l'eau ça se veut bon ça
se verra pas dans le registre fossile et
de toute façon pareil on n'a pas cette
capacité là en tout cas pas plus
développé que les autres animaux
terrestres donc maintenant quand on
regarde le registre fossile voit-on des
adaptations aux théologie de voit-on les
membres être plus dense que enfin le
tibia et c'est être plus plus dense et
plus épais chez nos ancêtres les
australopithèques et or or in et
ardipithecus et jusqu'à toumaï et ben
non on voit rien de tout ça
on voit très bien les adaptations mode
de vie arboricole notamment chez hardi
pittacus pour lesquelles on a des
squelettes complets chez
australopithecus aussi on a des
squelettes complets on voit bien les
adaptations à la bipédie alors les
adaptations arboricole je vais pas tout
vous les listes et vous les connaissez
si vous êtes allé au lycée vous vous les
connaissez les doigts arc et voilà les
pôles capable de se lever très très haut
la capacité de braque iations et puis
tout ce qui va être pouce opposable
opposable aux mains et aux pieds tout ça
c'est pour attraper voilà c pour
attraper les branches donc c'est des
adaptations à un mode de vie arboricole
donc là les adaptations au mode de vie
arboricole on les voit bien on voit des
adaptations à la bipédie mais comme je
les ai déjà expliqué considérer la
bipédie comme une adaptation mode de vie
aquatique c'est un peu fort de café
étant donné ce conseil les espèces
modernes donc on peut pas juste dire la
bipédie c'est ça l'adaptation au mode de
vie aquatique donc on a là des
adaptations à la bipédie mais pas
accompagnée de ce à quoi on s'attendrait
dans un mode de vie aquatique donc
qu'est ce qui nous reste je fais ces
fossiles voilà donc s assécher les
australopithèques les parents trope est
un diptyque us par exemple pour qui on a
des squelettes relativement complet
après on transition au genre homo et là
on a carrément d adaptation à la course
de fond qui apparaissent des alors homo
habilis on n'a pas de squelettes assez
complet mais on a au monal eddy qui
ressemble beaucoup au mot habilis même
si les plus jeunes qui a déjà un pied
qui est fondamentalement humain humains
modernes âge entend on à homo erectus
qui a aussi un pied fondamentalement
moderne
donc un pied avec tous les doigts
alignait donc le contraire de ce qu'on
attend d'une espèce aquatique encore une
fois qu'ils adaptent et à marcher dans
la vase les doigts sont tous enfin des
orteils sont tous alignés et c'est une
adaptation à la course de fond une fois
de plus donc et puis il ya tout ce qu'il
ya au niveau des genoux les genoux
rentrant etc tout ça c'est de la bipédie
mais bref c'est l'adaptation à la course
qui prime et donc la perte de des
adaptations à l'arborer collier au
niveau des membres antérieurs
notamment la perte des phalanges arqués
et l'allongement aussi du pouce enfin ou
du moelleux
le rétrécissement du ratio entre la
longueur des doigts ici de ces douala et
la longueur du pouce qui permet là la
saisie de précisions la saisie de
précision qui n'est pas possible chez un
chimpanzé parce que les chimpanzés ils
ont plus des proportions comme ça c'est
plus dur en fait pour eux de joindre
l'index et le pouce alors que nous on a
un puce très long comparé aux autres
doigts qui nous permet la saisie de
précisions donc ça c'est la perte de
l'arbre e-coli qui libère en fait qu'ils
libèrent en fait la capacité des mains à
saisir des objets et ça va notamment
permettre la fabrication d'outils bien
que les outils bien que les
australopithèques savez probablement
déjà fabriqué des outils rudimentaires
de l'industrie lomé quoi yens
donc ça c'est ce qu'on voit chez homo et
donc à partir d'un an au bout d'un
moment il ya même la domestication du
feu alors la domestication du feu ont la
place entre 400 mille cinq cent mille
ans il ya très récemment ils ont
découvert des traces de feu à tautavel
qui ont cinq cent soixante mille ans ils
sont pas encore sûrs d'eux si c'est
effectivement une
fois maîtrisé mais en tout cas c'est
super intéressant ce serait les plus
anciennes traces de feu
peut-être domestique et au monde donc
cinq cent mille ans 560 mille ans à
partir du moment où le feu est
domestique et j'ai envie de dire
c'est fin du game 1 il n'y a aucune
raison que nos ancêtres à partir de 500
mille ans soit aquatique donc le
registre fossile n'indique aucune
adaptation aura la mode de vie aquatique
ou semi aquatique à aucun moment de
l'évolution humaine et la théorie de la
du singe aquatique elle prévoit que donc
c'est là le fait d'être semi aquatique
qui a permis de se redresser
et d'avoir le cerveau qui qui augmente
de taille alors ça implique quand même
qu' on aurait une phase semi aquatique
qui irait au moins du début de la
bipédie de l'origine de la bipédie
jusqu'à l'apparition d'un cerveau de
grande taille
ce qui veut dire qu'en gros on couvre
tout depuis toumaï sahelanthropus
7,2 millions d'années à homo ergaster
voire même homo heidelbergensis
donc en bayard casters ça voudrait dire
au moins un million huit
d'années de millions d'années en gros et
si on prend et d'albert guen si cela ça
veut dire au moins jusqu'à il ya six ans
milan 500 600 mille ans
ça recouvre quand même un paquet de
millions d'années ce que vous imaginez
si le ça voudrait dire qu'il y aurait un
truc genre entre 4 et 6 millions
d'années d'évolution humaine dans l'eau
entre 4 et 6 millions d'années
d'évolution humaine dans le milieu
aquatique et la seule trace que ça
aurait laissé c'est juste la posture
bipèdes je le répète un 4 à 6 millions
d'années dans l'eau est la seule trace
que ça laisse derrière c'est des petits
machins des petits détails physiologique
complètement explicable autrement que
par une adaptation à la vie aquatique et
la posture bipèdes c'est tout ce qu'il
en resterait c'est un peu fort de café
c'est un peu balèze ça dépasserait
l'entendement comme diraient certains et
comme je les dis à partir de l'origine
du genre homo de toute façon là des
adaptations très franches à la course de
fond qui implique qu'ils vivaient pas
dans l'eau voilà et c'est marrant parce
que c'est justement à partir de
l'apparition du genre homo qu'on
commence à avoir des traces de
consommation de produits aquatiques
donc les premières traces de
consommation de tortues de tortues
aquatiques
d'hippopotames de crocodile de poisson
parce que c'est pareil à la théorie du
singe aquatica l'appliquent quand même
convive est ce beaucoup dans l'eau ça
veut dire qu'on normalement on devrait
consommer et notamment nos
australopithèques il aurait dû consommer
des produits de l'oim il aurait dû
consommer du poisson etc depuis sept
millions d'années depuis l'origine de la
bipédie qui est censé être la
conséquence de cette vie dans l'eau il
aurait dû consommer du poisson et ça
aurait dû laisser des traces un des
traces de dents au moins sur les autres
poissons des traces de reste on devrait
retrouver associés à chaque fois de
l'hominidé avec du poisson on devrait
retrouver des traces d'outils sur ce
poisson bas ça ça ne commence qu'à
partir de deux millions d'années et sa
date justement du genre homo qui est le
plus mauvais candidat à une adaptation
aux un mode de vie semi-aquatique donc
ça c'est une énorme incohérence que la
théorie du sein de l'aquatic ne peut pas
résoudre à l'heure actuelle et puis il
ya l'argument alors il ya le peut-être
la preuve qui est la plus souvent
avancée du point par les tenants du
singe aquatique c'est le fait que les
australopithèques notamment lucie par
exemple ont été retrouvés le plus
souvent dans des dépôts associé à de
l'eau des dépôts lacustre des dépôts de
rivières des dépôts de des dépôts de
plaines d'inondation notamment beaucoup
de dépôts de plaines d'inondation
donc ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont été
retrouvés dans l'eau ça veut dire qu'ils
ont été retrouvés dans des dépôts qui se
sont formés sous l'eau
bah ça avance et ça comme un argument en
faveur de l'hypothèse du singe aquatique
c'est quand même
démontré une énorme ignorance du
processus de fossilisation lui même
c'est juste parce que les fossiles enfin
c'est juste parce que les roches
sédimentaires
dans lesquelles les fossiles sont
préservés les roches sédimentaires ont
généralement besoin d'eau pour se former
parce que les roches sédimentaires cdu
sédiments et que ce sédiment il faut
qu'il se déposer qu'il soit cimenté et
ça ça implique qu'ils aient quelque
chose qui amène ce sédiment à cet
endroit là est généralement ces lots la
quasi-totalité des sédiments qui
existent dans le monde sont formés sous
l'eau en réalité que ce soit dans la mer
dans les rivières dans les dans les lacs
etc la quasi-totalité des sédiments se
forment sous l'eau les seuls contre
exemple ce sont les dépôts de dunes
qu'on appelle les os donc ce sont des
dépôts éolien c'est le vent qui amène
les sédiments donc on peut avoir des
fossiles dans ce genre de sédiments mais
autrement que ça la quasi-totalité des
sédiments dans lesquels on va retrouver
des fossiles bas ce sont par définition
formé dans l'eau le lot est un facteur
extrêmement importante permettant la
fossilisation mais dans l'absolu
retrouver un fossile dans un de ces
environnements là ça veut juste dire
qu'à un moment il ya eu un os et que
cette hausse s'est retrouvé sous l'eau
mais ça peut ça veut pas dire que
l'animal vivait dans l'eau tout au plus
ça veut dire que l'animal est mort dans
l'eau c'est là qu'il était à chier
d'ailleurs c'était pas un bon nageur
dans ce cas là ou alors même ça veut
dire que l'animal a vécu dans la savane
est mort son cadavre a commencé à se
décomposer il ya eu une tempête qui a
ramené de l'eau par dessus et de la boue
et la boue s'est consolidé et a préservé
sa ses plaines d'inondation et sinon si
on retrouve les restes dans une rivière
ça peut vouloir dire que l'eau une
inondation à ramener le cadavre dans le
lit de la rivière par ruissellement tout
simplement donc retrouver des fossiles
dans un milieu aquatique ça ne veut
absolument pas dire que l'animal vivait
en milieu aquatique et à chaque fois que
vous entendez cette interprétation c'est
une interprétation qui pue mais en tout
cas il vaut mieux rester prudent et de
toute façon comme je les dis c'est un
billet de fossilisation c'est juste un
simple biais de fossilisation
et la preuve que c'est juste un biais de
fossilisation nous vient des fossiles
d'afrique du sud les fossiles d'afrique
du sud d'hominidés les australopithèques
le genre homo et tout ça qu'on retrouve
en afrique du sud au monal eddy
australopithecus sediba
australopithecus africanus pour ne citer
que les plus connus on les a retrouvés
dans des grottes et dans des grottes
c'est le c'est pas parce que les
australopithèques vivaient dans l'eau à
12 degrés dans le noir à l'intérieur de
la grotte il vivait pas dans les lacs
qui se trouvait un terreau dégoûte c'est
parce que ils sont tombés il vivait dans
la savane sur le kst et ils sont tombés
dans des pièges naturels d'une façon ou
d'une autre à la soie de leur vivant
soit encore une fois par par
ruissellement des eaux de pluie mais ces
dépôts dans des grottes ce ne sont pas
du tout des dépôts formé en milieu
aquatique pour le coup ce sont des
dépôts qui indique très bien que les
australopithèques les eaux les
représentants du genre homo qui vivait
en afrique du sud n'était pas du tout
connecté au milieu aquatique et j'en
veux pour preuve le fait que d'une on
retrouve très très peu d'espèces
aquatiques dans ces dépôts de grottes
les hippopotames les loutres les enfin
les tout ce qui est un hymne aux semi
aquatiques y en a très très peu il ya
quasiment aucun crocodile dans l'est
dans les dépôts de grottes par exemple
si les australopithèques était
effectivement des espèces semi-aquatique
ce sont les seuls qu'on retrouve dans
les grottes ça c'est quand même
intéressant et et donc il ya très très
peu d'espèces semi-aquatique qu'on
retrouve dans ces dépôts de grotte mais
aussi on les retrouve en très très petit
nombre
donc ouais les australopithèques ce
serait réellement les seules exceptions
dans cette histoire ce sont ce seraient
les seuls pas si on admet que du coup la
théorie du singe aquatique est réel est
vrai bah on aurait cette énorme
exception registre fossile voilà tout
toutes les espèces qu'on retrouve dans
ces dépôts de grottes la grande majorité
de ces espèces sont des antilopes des
zèbres des espèces qui vivent dans la
savane des grands prédateurs
et puis on aurait les australopithèques
qui seraient les seules espèces semi
aquatique qui se retrouvaient là oui bon
ça reste quand même plus parcimonieux
d'admettre que les
que les australopithèques vivaient parmi
les antilopes et les zèbres et les
machins et se sont retrouvés dans les
grottes exactement de la même façon que
tout le reste quoi j'attends qu'il ya
pas de raison à ça et que ce qu'on voit
en afrique de l'est dans l'est dans les
dépôts lacustres et de rivières et de
plaines d'inondation bah c'est ni plus
ni moins qu'un billet de fossilisation à
savoir que c'est en ces sédiments que se
forment les fossiles de toute façon donc
il n'y a pas de chances de les retrouver
ailleurs que la cua et puis un argument
finale qui et ce souvent avancé aussi
par rapport à la fossilisation c'est
celle des singes pourquoi on retrouve
pas d'autres sages notamment d'autres
grands singes en même temps que les
australopithèques dans ces dépôts
justement dans ces dépôts pourquoi
pourquoi est ce qu a pas de fossiles de
grands singes pourquoi n'y a pas de
registre fossile devant sache pourquoi
il ya que les australopithèques et homo
et ses bas déjà c'est ignorer le
registre fossile des singes parce qu'en
réalité des singes il y en a surtout des
cercopithèque savoir des babouins on
retrouve des sages des babouins en même
temps que les australopithèques donc il
ya certes les grands singes sont portés
manquants mais en même temps les grands
singes quand vous connaissez la taille
des populations actuelles qui sont pas
énormes et que et qu'on prend en compte
le fait qu'ils vivent dans les forêts
essentiellement ces grands singes des
forêts tropicales qui sont de très
mauvais sites fossilifères forêts
tropicales qui encore aujourd'hui sont
des forêts tropicales donc le problème
c'est qu'on peut pas aller creuser
puisque il ya pas d'affleurements va
dire faut quand même qu'il ya un
affleurement faut quand même qu'on ait
accès à la roche
sachant que les forêts tropicales de
l'époque sont toujours les forêts
tropicales d'aujourd'hui c'est quand
même embêtant et puis dans ces forêts
tropicales comme je disais c'est des
milieux où la terre est très acide où le
sol est très épais il ya très peu de
fossilisation dans les milieux tropiques
dans les milieux de forêts tropicales
donc on peut très bien expliquer
l'absence de grands singes dans les
dépôts où l'on trouve des
australopithèques c'est pas parce que
les australopithèques était
particulièrement friand de la flotte on
n'a pas besoin de cette théorie du singe
aquatique pour expliquer pourquoi n'y a
pas de grands sages dans les dépôts où
l'on trouve les australopithèques et on
trouve d'autres sages comme les
cercopithèque aux ide par exemple on les
trouve en abondance
scc recopie technoïde c'est babouins
sont très très terrestre toute façon
niveau singes aquatique on n'est pas non
plus je ne connais pas d'espèces de
singes aquatique alors y aller les
macaques à face rouge qui vivent là dans
les réseaux hydrothermales en rouge
japon mais enfin faut bien voir que
national geographic qu'ils assistent
beaucoup quand ils font leurs
documentaires sur les macaques à face
rouge qui se baignent dans l'eau dans
l'eau qui bouillonne comme ça il insiste
beaucoup moi surtout ceux sur la
centaine de sage autour de la qui sont
en train de se peupler le cul dans la
neige autour de 1 ça il ya que les
dominants qui vivent dans l'eau et puis
d'ailleurs ils vivent pas dans l'eau ils
vont juste s'y tremper le cul pour se
réchauffer et puis c'est tout donc ils
sont pas spécialement aquatique ces
singes et puis on allait les nazis que
je crois qu'ils sont capables de nager
sont des rares singes capable de nager
instinctivement mais sinon à part ça des
singes aquatique ça n'existe pas
réellement de toute façon donc
donc à partir du moment où vous trouvez
des sages dans un dépôt donc des
babouins par exemple savalli totalement
que votre registre fossile est
uniquement composée d'espèces
semi-aquatique puis comme j'ai dit il ya
les zèbres ya les antilopes il ya
quelques antilopes qui peuvent être un
petit peu semi aquatiques comme les
water bugs et les sites à thoune gamme
est apparu je veux dire de la plupart
des antilopes sont très adaptés à la
sécheresse
donc et ça on en retrouve beaucoup avec
les australopithèques aussi dont bref le
registre fossile n'indique absolument
pas absolument aucune adaptation à la
vie aquatique mais en plus cela dit qu
aucun
ya aucune raison en fait que de
considérer à aucun moment que l'être
humain soit passé enfin que la lignée
humaine soit passer par une phase
aquatiques à aucun moment alors
maintenant intéressant nous aux
prédictions on a vu que les espèces
modernes n'a dit que rien en terme
d'adaptation à la vie aquatique de
relation avec la bipédie tout ça ne se
passe rien on a vu les fossiles le
registre fossile pareil ici passe rien
qui indique vaguement une phase
aquatiques dans l'évolution humaine
maintenant les prédictions que fait la
théorie du singe aquatiques en termes
d'évolution
on peut se poser la question est ce
qu'elles ont eu réellement lieu c'est à
dire en gros si vous émettez une théorie
alors elle a des conséquences attendues
cette théorie comme je l'avais déjà
expliqué dans une vidéo précédente quand
on a vu que les cétacés avaient des
poumons avaient des palettes natatoire
qui était organisée exactement comme les
bras des mammifères terrestres on a fait
l'hypothèse que c'est que en cherchant
suffisamment loin dans le registre
fossile on devrait rencontrer des
baleines à quatre pattes des cétacés à
quatre pattes prédictions qui s'est
réalisé donc l'appareil avec l'hypothèse
du singe aquatique on devrait pouvoir
faire des prédictions qui normalement
devrait se réaliser donc cette cette
théorie elle nous dit que l'hominisation
donc là la stature bipèdes et
l'augmentation de la taille du cerveau
serait dû donc à la poussée d'archimède
ayant permis à l'être humain de se
redresser et de mieux supporter le poids
de son gros cerveau
en tout cas nos ancêtres des êtres
humains d'arriver à accomplir ça alors
les prédictions déjà on a vu les la
première prédiction qui serait on
devrait trouver des fossiles qui vont
dans ce sens là voilà voilà on a déjà
fait le tour
les adaptations est ce que l'être humain
présente des adaptations bas on on peut
ce qu'on peut se poser la question donc
les adaptations on a dit quelles
seraient les adaptations d'un homininés
qui serait capable de marcher debout
dans l'eau en tenant sa tête comme ça eh
ben ce serait d'avoir comme je les dis
des tibias des fémurs et des tares des
os du tarse pâquis ostéo sclérotique à
savoir épais et très dense pour
justement agir comme des ballasts
maintenant votre être humain avec les
pieds au fond de l'eau solidement et la
tête soutenu par le parlement
sa limite quand même vachement la
tranche d'eau dans laquelle d'entre être
humain est capable de vivre - axa y
coulait plus que ça il peut plus
soutenir sa tête mais bref on va partir
on va passer de la de l'absurdité de
cette situation juste pour dire voilà on
devrait trouver un être humain qui
auraient des jambes très épaisses des os
des jambes très épais et danse et avec
des vertèbres cervicales qui serait très
faible évidemment si l'être humain n'a
pas évolué sa bipédie sur terre les
vertèbres cervicales et la musculature
du coup devrait être tout faible au
moment de la sortie de l'eau et ça ça
vous donne quand même un truc qui est
moyennement viable c'est à dire que la
prédiction que l'hominisation a eu lieu
dans l'eau elle vous donne un être
humain qui va avoir du mal à sortir de
l'eau du coup parce qu'il pourra pas
soutenir le poids de sa tête et puis
qu'il aura les jambes super lourdes pour
se déplacer sur la terre ferme
bon bah on parle aussi du fait que
normalement il aurait dû sortir de l'eau
avec les doigts écartés et non pas avec
les doigts resserré comme enfin les
doigts et les orteils écarté et non pas
les orteils resserré comme on voit sur
les empreintes de pas d'homo ergaster ou
les empreintes de pas même
d'australopithecus je rappelle qu'on a
les empreintes de la et au lit sur les
empreintes de laetoli le pouce opposable
et 1 pen opposé
donc les doigts étaient déjà qu'enfin
les orteils était déjà quand même bien
alignées sur les sur les pieds d'un
australopithèque donc on a cette
prédiction qui normalement produit un
être humain viable bipèdes sous l'eau
mais qui produit aussi un être humain
qui du coup ne marche pas une fois qu'il
essaye de revenir sur terre et le truc
c'est que il faut bien qu'ils reviennent
sur terre puisque au bout d'un moment
faut que ça donne nous
donc faut bien qu'à un moment ils
reviennent sur terre cet être humain à
être humain ylang-ylang n'est que très
très très moyennement capable parce
qu'il peut pas soutenir le poids de sa
grosse tête
voilà il ya aussi comme je le disais le
fait qu' il fallait ça l'une des autres
prédictions c'est que l'être humain est
semi aquatique au moins du moment où il
développe la bipédie jusqu'au moment où
il développe un gros cerveau sauf que
comme je l'aï dit il ya selon ce que
vous appelez un gros cerveau
c'est-à-dire le gros cerveau d'homo
erectus coup le gros cerveau de mme
wildenberg n 6 au moins deux libériennes
6 qui a un cerveau qui est de la à peu
près de la taille du nôtre alors que
homo ergaster donc l'homo erectus
africain il a un cerveau qui fait la
moitié de la taille du nôtre donc en
fonction de ce que vous appelez un gros
cerveau bas toute la phase
semi-aquatique s'étend au moins jusque
là
et enfin je veux dire c'est quand même
très contradictoire avec la théorie de
d'un sage aquatique d'une phase
aquatique qui aurait laissé très peu de
traces la prédiction ce serait plutôt
que la bipédie et le cerveau aurait dû
se développer en même temps du coup sauf
que c'est pas le cas ça c'est pas du
tout développés en même temps ces deux
événements qui sont séparés par
plusieurs millions d'années ce qui
oblige d'ailleurs à rallonger cette
phase semi aquatique ce qui rend
d'autant plus improbable le fait
qu'aujourd'hui tel qu'on nous regarde on
est quasiment aucune adaptation au
milieu aquatique
non contestable comme je le dis encore
une fois les preuves recevables cdd
adaptation incontestable au mode de vie
aquatique tout ce qui est
preuves circonstancielles ça ne marche
pas ça c'est une autre prédiction et
puis le lot de la dernière prédiction
c'est normalement si la bipédie est
associé à l'évolution à une adaptation
mode de vie aquatique on devrait avoir
une
consommation des produits de l'eau dès
l'origine de la bipédie or cette
consommation des produits de l'eau
n'arrive comme je les dis qu'à partir de
deux millions d'années donc encore une
fois il ya cette espèce de fossé entre
la date prédite par la théorie et le
début réel du registre archéologique de
la consommation de produits de l'eau
sept millions d'années pour la bipédie 2
millions d'années pour la consommation
de produits issus de milieux aquatiques
dont toutes les prédictions faites par
la théorie de
du singe aquatique la théorie aquaman
sont fausses se sont avérées fausses il
n'y a aucune prédiction qui marche en
tout cas les prédictions les plus
évidentes que je puisse vous donner là
maintenant aucune prédiction n'est
validé ce qui de fait falsifier la
théorie voilà la théorie la théorie va
falloir la patch est au mieux ou va
falloir l'abandonner au pire donc pour
conclure grand 1 1 les espèces modernes
ne valide pas une association entre
bipédie et et vie aquatique grands de
leur registre fossile et archéologiques
ne soutient absolument pas une origine
aquatique de l'être humain grand troyes
les prédictions de la théorie du singe
aquatique
sont toutes fausses sont toutes
falsifiés donc la conclusion logique
c'est que la théorie est un échec dans
son état actuel la théorie du singe
aquatique ne marche pas elle ne
fonctionne pas et le truc maintenant
c'est que bas il ya encore des gens qui
la défendent et pour la défendre qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils vont faire
certainement ce que vous faites depuis
le début de cette vidéo dans les
commentaires à savoir ils construisent
des esquives il dodge comme ça plein
on esquive les contre-arguments hop on
va à droite on va à gauche et donc vous
allez finir par me sortir l excuse que
oui mais l'être humain donc n'a
peut-être aucune adaptation aujourd'hui
et peut-être qu'il ya pas de registre
fossile de ces adaptations parce que
l'être humain n'était qu'un n'était qu
un primate aquatique intermittents voilà
un peu comme le macaque à face rouge
joue les nazis qu
on a des nappes adaptation physiologique
à la vie aquatique
précisément parce que ben on n'était que
dès que des primates aquatique
intermittents où vivaient pas assez
longtemps pour développer des
adaptations franche et distinguables
d'un mode de vie terrestre le fonds d
adaptation pour lesquels on peut les
pointer du doigt et dira ça c'est vie
aquatique ça c'est rien d'autre que vie
aquatique donc l' esquive ultime bah
c'est de dire que bah finalement l'être
humain oui l'être humain à une phase
aquatiques mais ce n'était pas une phase
aquatique très prononcé du coup elle n'a
pas laissé d'adaptation elle n'a pas
laissé de preuves
d'accord donc vous acceptez totalement
d'esquiver jusqu'à atteindre le point de
non réfutabilité c'est à dire que vous
vous esquivez les réfutations jusqu'à
être perché sur le point d'y
réfutabilité à savoir ma théorie n'est
plus scientifique
c'est bien moi depuis tout à l'heure
j'essaie de vous aider en proposant des
vraies preuves possibles et vous ce que
vous faites c'est que vous esquivez
jusqu'à atteindre le point où en dealant
ou en fait je peux plus vous réfutez bah
oui mais je suis d'accord mais si vous
n'êtes plus réfutable vous n'êtes plus
scientifique vous venait d'atteindre la
pseudo-science s'il n'y a pas de preuve
visite le possible de cette adaptation
au mode de vie aquatique que vous
essayez de défendre votre théorie vient
d'atteindre le point de la licorne rose
invisible sur le marché des idées c'est
la licorne euros invisible vous ne
pouvez pas me prouver qu'elles
n'existent pas parce qu'elle est
invisible elle est irréfutable malicorne
euros invisible laissera pas
d'empreintes de pas parce que c'est une
licorne elle est légère comme une plume
elle fait elle fait caca d arc en ciel
mais c'est arc en ciel vous ne les
verrez pas parce que c'est une licorne
euros invisible donc elle ne laisse
aucune trace malicorne eurose invisible
et vous ne pourrez pas prouvé qu'elle ne
pourrait pas me prouver qu'elles
n'existent pas eh bien votre théorie du
singe aquatique elle vient d'atteindre
le point de la licorne de rosa visible
dans le sens où elle n'a laissé aucune
trace c'est la fin de la scientificité
de la théorie du singe aquatique donc
pour conclure cette première vidéo cette
réfutation de la théorie du sage
aquatique c'est que la théorie du sage
aquatique elle produit des prédictions
qui se réalise pas et elle elle ne
survit que en esquivant les réfutations
jusqu'à atteindre le point où ça devient
quasiment impossible de la réfuter donc
belle et la gauche deux cases de la
pseudo-science donc c'est pour ça que la
plupart des paléoanthropologues
considère que la théorie du singe
aquatique n'est qu'une fantaisie c est
une pseudo science est le seul moyen
pour arriver à continuer à survivre
c'est de continuer à produire des
mauvais arguments que nous allons voir
dans les deux prochaines vidéos et une
fois qu'on a réfuté tous ces mauvais
argument bas c'est de nous dire oui mais
tu peux pas prouver qu'il n'ya jamais eu
à aucun moment une petite phase
aquatique qui aurait laissé aucune trace
derrière elle bah ouais mais une fois
que vous avez hâte à ce point là la
théorie est morte enfin les
scientifiquement morte vous pouvez
continuer à jouer avec dans le coin des
mauvais élèves la balle avec un petit
chapeau dan parce que le petit chapeau
danemark et pseudo-sciences mais c'est
tout ce que vous pouvez faire là c'est
bon elle a quitté la cour des grands et
on en parle plus voilà je vous retrouve
pour la seconde vidéo où cette fois on
va commencer à s'attaquer à des contenus
qui défendent cette théorie ou où on va
s'amuser aller à la prochaine